[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 30 janvier
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
j'en ai de fronde sociale aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines de rassemblement dans
le département contre l'action du
gouvernement
elle a emmené par les personnels des pas
de l'autre par les retraités nous
recevons d'ailleurs les représentants
des retraités des syndicats de la cgt et
fsu 78 une concertation publique lancée
à villepreux elle concerne l'aménagement
du secteur trianon pour mener ce projet
est la municipalité a fait le choix
d'associer les habitants une première
réunion se tenait en fin de semaine
dernière
reportage à suivre enfin son périple
vient de se terminer à 70 ans alain
crampons à réaliser le tour de cuba à
vélo un voyage de deux mois sur l'île
des caraïbes pour cet habitant de bois
d'arcy qui n'en était pas à son coup
d'essai alain crampons qui est notre
invité pour revenir sur son aventure
mais avant de développer ses tripes
comprend tout de suite la direction du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines retrouver avec
camille lambert bonsoir est la cérémonie
des voeux de l'agglomération s'y tient
ce soir c'est dans quelques heures avec
bien sûr le discours du président jean
michel fourgous et plusieurs points
importants à camille seront abordés au
cours de ce discours
bonsoir grégory et oui ce sont les
premiers voeux de jean michel fourgous
en tant que président de saint quentin
en yvelines
le maire les républicains d'elancourt a
été élu président de l'agglomération en
octobre dernier il succède à michel
laugier des voeux qu'il a ce côté
orienté sur les grands événements
sportifs de 2010 8 à commencer par
l'open de france de golf au golf
national qui se tiendra du 29 juin au 2
juillet événement devenu incontournable
ces dernières années sur le territoire
est un bon moyen pour se tester aussi
avant la ryder cup évidemment très
attendu à saint quentin en yvelines qui
se prépare en ce moment même pour
accueillir soixante mille visiteurs par
jour du 25 au 30 septembre 2018 et sans
oublier que cette cérémonie des voeux se
déroule
la drôme nationale qui est juste
derrière moi un des lieux clés des jeux
olympiques 2000 24 qui se tiendront à
paris et en dehors du sport d'autres
grands projets seront évoqués notamment
la ligne 18 ça dont l'arrivée fait débat
du côté des antilles on s'inquiète des
possibles conséquences de cette ligne
sur les terres agricoles mais surtout
chez ses défenseurs ont la juge
indispensable pour mieux desservir le
territoire notamment en vue des jeux
olympiques
les élus de saint quentin en yvelines se
sont déjà mobilisés à plusieurs reprises
pour préserver le tracé est l'échéance
2024 une ligne qui participent au projet
plus global du grand paris express qui
vise à transformer l'agglomération
parisienne en une grande métropole
incluant donc la grande couronne ce sera
aussi l'occasion de l'évoquer
et puis à plus localement le président
de l'agglomération parlera des nouveaux
projets d'aménagement en matière du bras
d'urbanisme de la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux et enfin fer de lance
de jean michel fourgous il sera bien sûr
question d'économie notamment du
développement des entreprises sur le
territoire et l'accompagnement des
chercheurs d'emploi merci camille à
patrick jacques de dixmude aux moyens
techniques qui on reviendra sur cette
cérémonie à des voeux dans notre édition
de demain soir il était le 9ème prix est
vice-président justement de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et premier
adjoint à la mairie à del en cours
depuis 22 ans et gerald de favier a
présenté récemment sa démission de tous
ses mandats l'ancien élu faisait ses
adieux hier lors d'une cérémonie au
gymnase chastagner à elancourt et jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt lui
a consacré un discours départ à la
retraite pour gerald de famille à 78
dans le loiret pour se rapprocher
notamment de sa famille et c'est un
gerald de favier ému que vous allez
écouter tout de suite au micro de
camille lambert s'est énormément
d'émotion
c'est un moment difficile que de quitter
à la fois ce poste que j'occupais depuis
22 ans
et puis surtout cette belle commune
d'elancourt que j'aime par dessus tout
je serai bien évidemment toujours
disponible pour mes collègues ou pour
monsieur le maire si tant est qu'ils
aient besoin de moi pour revenir sur un
dossier que je connais tout
particulièrement ou pour les aider mais
je pense qu'ils auront pas besoin de moi
ils sont aussi extrêmement pertinent est
extrêmement compétent est ce les
prémices d'un mouvement social d'ampleur
en france après les agents
pénitentiaires
le personnel des maisons de retraite et
les retraités eux mêmes se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui il dénonce la
politique du gouvernement l'un de ces
mouvements avaient lieu devant la
préfecture des yvelines à versailles est
les précisions avec patrick jacques de
dixmude quentin le frère et nicolas
kirilow liste de rassemblement
deux lieux différents mais une seule et
même cible retraités et personnels d pad
dénonce la politique du gouvernement
mouvement principal celui des maisons de
retraite partout en france et dans les
yvelines
le mouvement est inédit pour le secteur
à l'appel de l'ensemble des syndicats et
des directeurs d'établissement pour
réclamer notamment une hausse des
effectifs
le problème c'est qu'on ne réussit même
pas à respecter le rythme des résidents
et surtout à respecter leur autonomie ce
qui fait qu'on fait des fois des choses
à leur place parce qu'on peut pas les on
peut pas prendre le temps pour les aider
on ressent bien les familles ce qu'elles
disent
l'axé fait vite il ya aussi les
toilettes les bains qui sont peut-être
pas donner forcément régulièrement et
voudront donner beaucoup plus elles ne
peuvent pas ou des douches
c'est une dégradation quand même au
niveau 2
la prise en charge de la personne âgée
plus tôt dans la journée ce sont les
retraités qui se sont réunis devant la
préfecture à versailles hausse de la csg
gel des pensions baisse des apl la
colère et variés contre le gouvernement
et pour la défense du porte-monnaie de
pouvoir d'achat diminue d'année en année
depuis au moins c'est pas en fin de de
plus que moi j'ai pris ma retraite je
sais que mon pouvoir d'achat a diminué
donc je trouve que c'est pas juste et
que c'est toujours la même chose que les
actionnaires s'enrichissent emmanuel
macron président des riches l'argument
social est désormais rodée et pourrait
être encore développé jeudi avec une
nouvelle manifestation prévue
cette fois ci contre la réforme du bac
et la nouvelle plateforme parcours sup
et pour parler justement de cette
mobilisation des retraités à versailles
aujourd'hui j'accueille en plateau deux
invités maria bollinger représentants
des retraités pour le syndicat fsu 78 et
à ma droite michel shaffner pour la cgt
soixante dix huit merci d'être avec nous
bonsoir à tous les deux alors c'était
une intersyndicale ce matin qui était
donc le douala à la préfecture pour ce
mouvement une grogne qui est général
chez chez les retraités on peut le dire
et vous en avez profité d'ailleurs pour
remettre à cette occasion des cartes de
voeux revendicative à à emmanuel macron
que contiennent ces cartes maria alors
donc effectivement nous avons déposé 480
cartes de voeux à la préfecture à
l'intention du président de la
république pour se rappeler à son bon
souvenir puisque il y a une très forte
colère des retraités
à cette rentrée on le voit en janvier
2018 tout augmente je ne rentre pas dans
les détails mais chacun peut le
constater
mais le président a déjà annoncé que le
blocage des pensions qui fait suite à
des blocages depuis plusieurs années et
qui fait suite à des amputations
successives des pensions par des mesures
fiscales successives est alors cette
fois ci en janvier 2018
les pensions des 60 % des retraités est
impacté par la hausse de la csg une
hausse de 25% de la csg c'est effectif
depuis le 1er janvier voilà donc sur les
pensions que vont découvrir leur les
retraités effectivement il ya des
amputations très importantes alors il a
été dit que c'étaient les retraités
riches qui était impacté donc qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un retraité riche pour
monsieur macron un retraité riches c'est
un célibataire qui touchent une pension
de 1200 euros
il sera impacté par la csg il perdra 200
euros à l'année un couple riche de
retraités pour monsieur macron c'est une
infirmière par exemple qui part avec 970
euros de retraite
son conjoint employé municipal par avec
1100 euros de retraite ils sont à moins
de 2000 euros ensemble ils sont en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté chacun pour
leur retraite
enfin les pirates réellement laissé au
quotidien ils seront soumis à la csg et
ils perdront 400 euros sur l'année voilà
alors deux principaux griefs vous l'avez
évoqué c'est l'augmentation de la csg
qui est effective depuis le 1er janvier
il y aussi la baisse de la pl c'est
l'aide au logement personnalisé je vous
propose d'écouter à ce propos le député
modem de la 9e circonscription adhésives
l'insee bruno myle yens je comprends
bien l'histoire de la csg alors que la
suppression à pelves habitations raid
sur trois ans dont 3 ans ça sera
compensée compenser largement compensé
+1 90% d'entre eux donc de ce côté là il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir quand
même c'est que leurs revenus vont
fatalement
mon remonter mécaniquement au plus tard
dans trois ans après la baisse des
appels on va voir on à la loi logement
qui arrive effectivement le problème
c'est que la baisse d athènes a été plus
un effet d'aubaine que d'autre chose ça
n'a rien résolu à la crise du logement
c'est pour ça qu'on va faire une loi sur
le logement qui veulent mieux cerner les
problèmes des uns et des autres et on va
se passer de l'attelle mer on trouvera
un système dans la veille dans la loi
logement qui permettent l'accès au
logement social oui je comprends
l'inquiétude
et ça c'est la première chose et non ils
ont par exemple s'inquiéter michel
schaffner pour bruno myle yens député
modem qui est donc alliée à la
république en marche le parti de la
majorité présidentielle
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir
notamment sur la siège et elle dit
qu'elle sera cette hausse de la csg sera
compensée en trois ans pour les
retraités par la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation ça ne vous rassure pas pour
pour non non pas du tout d'abord ils
parlent de tout autre de trois ans mais
les retraités ils ont besoin de vivre
aujourd'hui
maintenant et c'est maintenant qu'ils
auront la baisse de leurs delà de leurs
revenus
d'autre part la taxe d'habitation
nous on est inquiet parce que ça sera
encore des dotations - pour la coller
aux collectivités territoriales et on
sait que tout ça ça peut impacter toutes
les aides au financement et notamment de
la protection sociale par exemple il ya
eu les luttes des ehpad aujourd'hui et
on sait que les les départements
participent au financement des étals
d'autre part les l'association des
maires de france déjà réfléchissent à la
manière quand il faut remplacer là c'est
la baisse de la taxe d'habitation
donc ça nous rassure pas du tout nous on
pense que mon post on a la preuve est on
le sait qu'il ya eu vraiment une baisse
du niveau de vie des retraités depuis
plusieurs années il ya eu les oreilles
3% de la casa il ya eu le gel des
pensions pendant quatre ans je veux
conscient qu'il sera et moins maintenue
jusqu'à l'église qui va être maintenu et
donc moi j'aimerais savoir comment le
député qui a parlé pourrait vivre avec
la pression qui ont des millions de
retraités en france dans les yvelines il
ya deux cent quarante mille retraités et
parmi eux il y en a au moins 40% qui ont
moins de 1200 euros pour vivre par mois
la question est posée les bras lui de
répondre à cela dernière chose il nous
reste moins d'une minute les prochaines
actions qui vont être menées quelles
sont-elles pour pour vous je voudrais
juste dire que bien sûr nous soutenons
l'action qui a été menée aujourd'hui
dans les ehpad 1 d'ailleurs nos
organisations syndicales soutenait ce
mouvement et nous nous inscrivons avec
les neuf organisations qui impulsent
l'action au niveau des retraités au
niveau national dans des actions
diversifiées
donc nous allons poursuivre bien sûr les
demandes de rendez vous auprès des
députés des yvelines nous espérons qu'il
nous recevrons parce que le journal
notamment par or bergeron à l'avant bras
nous avons été reçus pas d'énergie
mais il y encore de nombreux députés
sénateurs qui n'ont même pas daigné
répondre à notre demande de rendez-vous
ce depuis plusieurs mois donc nous
réitérons c'est demain pour nous faire
entendre et puis nous avons donc ça
c'est pour les actions au sein du
département
si vous avez une action nains
perspectives d'action nationale le 15
mars à l'appel donc des 9 organisations
de retraités organisations syndicales et
associations
donc là ce sera un mouvement d'envergure
nationale merci à vous deux maria
bolzinger et michel le chef nord d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle vous êtes
représentant des retraités pour deux
syndicats maria bolzinger pour la fsu 78
michel shaffner pour la cgt des yvelines
merci encore dans l'actualité également
le département placé toujours ce soir en
vigilance orange
inondations 2000 à 400 foyers évinois
sont concernés qui de crue atteint hier
sur le secteur seine paris que vous
voyez sur ces images à bougival sur la
zone à des boucles de seine en aval de
conflans sainte honorine à la montée des
eaux devrait atteindre son maximum dans
la journée de demain et des opérations
de mise en sécurité d'assistance se
poursuivent les pompiers des yvelines
sont intervenus déjà plus de 200
reprises conséquences des inondations
des coupures d'électricité bien sûr est
mais aussi des conditions de circulation
très difficiles sur trois axes et
notamment les axes des ponts les accès
au pont du pecq de fin d'oise et de
poissy à des points réguliers sur la
situation sont à consulter sur le site
de la préfecture des yvelines
un sujet plus locale à présent
villepreux associé à ses habitants au
projet d'aménagement du secteur trianon
à cette volonté de la municipalité a été
lancée jeudi dernier par une première
réunion publique elle servait à définir
les grandes lignes de ce projet la
concertation se veut participative et va
durer 12 mois
les détails avec au rayon des villes
prose yen et des villes prussiens
curieux de connaître le futur visage du
quartier central de leur ville
pour cette première concertation
publique l'espace michel petrucciani a
fait le plein la mairie a souhaité
associer les habitants pour
l'aménagement du secteur du trianon et
de ses alentours
consultez le public les habitants et
comprendre leurs
préoccupation par rapport à ce qui va
être indiqués c'est toujours intéressant
de le faire de yuuwaa nous sommes
nombreux à être venus ce soir donc nous
sommes tous pour la plupart très
concernés ce projet fait suite à
l'élaboration du nouveau plu le plan
local d'urbanisme
objectif de cette première réunion
définir la méthode de concertation
proposée aux villes prochain durant les
douze prochains mois en fait ville
procès construites à des époques
successives comme beaucoup de villes par
par l'apport de nouveaux quartiers c'est
un quartier qui est au croisement de
tous ces quartiers et qui doit nous
permettre de
de créer du lien entre ces différentes
époques de construction de villepreux et
surtout d'améliorer le fonctionnement
global de la ville si pour l'instant
aucune piste sur les aménagements prévus
n'a été lancé d'autres réunions et
ateliers sont prévus
prochain rendez vous le 10 février sur
la place du marché pour une balade
urbaine
les habitants peuvent également donner
leur avis par mail ou en mairie
c'est chaque mardi dans le 7 8 jours n'a
le portrait de la rédaction est
consacrée à ce soir à sophie bennabi
cette grille en courtoise de 27 ans a
décidé de changer de voie
professionnelle elle était ingénieur en
informatique elle a décidé de devenir
spécialiste en médecine indienne une
rencontre signée par michael et demi
d'euros et nicolas d'android pour
saboter un arrêt du pipa lee du poivrot
long je vais vous monter parce que vous
connaissez pas avec du lait des
conseillers en thérapie donner aux
élèves se fit bennabi suit une formation
à urt veda avec joyce willaume le don
thérapeute et formatrice spécialisée
dans cette médecine indienne
c'est une élève qui est assidu qui est
très enthousiaste qui a déjà participé à
la journée de l'ayurveda en tant que
comme masseuse et qui est très dynamique
dans le groupe
une journée avec des patients les élèves
apprennent à gérer une consultation un
questionnaire à suivre pour permettre de
mieux connaître son patient avant de
passer à l'auscultation l'or va prendre
votre pouls pour voir les dochards par
les énergies qui sont un déséquilibre
dans votre organisme
ça ça correspond au dos chavatte a donc
au dos chat qui correspond aux éléments
de l'air de l'air et de l'espace le
majeur celle aisément de l'eau et du feu
et l'annulaire c'est les éléments de la
terre et de l'eau et donc en fait ça ça
nous permet de déceler les dochards donc
y en a 3 bat à pita et capa est de
savoir donc d'où provient le
déséquilibre par rapport aux éléments
que je viens de citer
moi j'écris ce matin on craque région
plus tard un poids s'échauffent assez
long quand on a un excès de pita c'est
quand on a beaucoup de feu donc ça va se
traduire par des inflammations par
beaucoup de colère par beaucoup de
volonté de contrôler en fait sa vie et
son travail
à 27 ans sophie bennabi suit cette
deuxième année elle a commencé sa
formation de médecine indienne en
octobre 2016 il ya un an le décide de
changer de vie professionnelle elle
quitte son poste d'ingénieur en
informatique et se reconvertit dans
l'activité ayurvédique l'ayurveda c'est
arrivé un petit peu par hasard en lisant
des livres en tombant sur des articles
sur internet voilà coup de foudre
donc c'est une médecine indienne qui
veut dire en fait la science de la vie
et les remèdes à saveur sciences de la
vie et c'est une médecine en fait qui
allie l'alimentation les soins corporels
et la spiritualité avec ces outils le
thérapie a reçoit chez elle une à deux
personnes par semaine pour des soins
l'ayurveda massage consultations
médicales conseil bien-être différentes
prestations thérapeutique avec des
tarifs entre 40 et 55 euros les séances
mélangé à ces révisions je revois les
cours que jean présentiel sur paris dans
mon école valeur vénale et puis je lis
des livres en fête des livres
les livres les livres sacrés de lier
vidal est traité de la verveine à qu'on
va apprendre en fait ce qu'on appelle
les textes classiques donc je dirais vie
je les apprends j'essaie de classées par
thématiques en décembre dernier sophie
bennabi partie pendant un mois en inde
elle a pu bénéficier de conseils de
professionnels dans un hôpital
ayurvédique c'était plutôt des patients
en fait que j'ai rencontré et bats la
structure de l'hôpital fin les personnes
qui s'occupaient de la structure de
l'hôpital que j'ai rencontré aussi donc
vraiment des personnes qui étaient
baignées dans la leur veinard ce fut bel
habit souhaite faire de nouveaux voyages
en inde pour pouvoir affiner sa
formation en ayurveda pendant que le
soleil se cache ici lui a fait le plein
de vitamine d il nous revient des
caraïbes depuis le 19 janvier alain
crampons bonsoir vous êtes habitants de
bois d'arcy à 70 ans vous avez vous
venez de réaliser un tour de cuba à vélo
vous êtes revenu donc récemment elle 19
janvier deux mois de voyage d'aventuré
d'anecdotes peut-être vous allez nous en
parler dans un instant comment s'est
déroulé ce périple vous étiez fixés au
début un objectif de 2000 km est ce que
vous avez pu atteindre cet objectif dans
l en fait c'est un demi tour que j'ai
fait puisque ouais j'ai arrêté le 19
janvier au lieu du 8 février
mais j'ai préféré rester sur une sur
deux bonnes de bonnes ondes à midi bonne
dynamique plutôt que de revenir avec
quelques risques de déception parce que
c'est compliqué ses complices logés sur
place comment comment on fait vous êtes
allés dans des auberges chez l'habitant
comment ça s'est déroulé chez l'habitant
parce que le camping est interdit ou
réservées aux cubains et le mot camping
n'a pas la même signification là bas
qu'ici d'accord donc il faut privilégier
les casas particulière particulière et
c'est là où le problème se pose quand on
est un voyageur ou à pied ou à vélo
comme moi parce que
il est difficile de réserver par
téléphone
parce que d'abord ça coûte très très
cher quand on est européen
le internet c'est compliqué il faut une
carte
ensuite il faut trouver la carte se veut
travailler une heure pour la trouver
quand il ya toujours la queue ensuite
retrouver l'endroit dans la ville où il
ya un parc ou un hôtel qui est
susceptible de recevoir les ans et on se
référait pleut ensuite il faut se
connecter faut pas qu'il y ait trop de
monde pour que donc c'est assez qu'on
avait envie de garder quelques anecdotes
vous lui viennent à l'esprit quand vous
pensez vous repensez à ce voyage
alors c'est essentiellement quand je
quitte les grandes villes la havane à
mon avis bon une fois qu'on a fait 3-3
nuit c'est déjà pas mal
parce que c'est très bruyant c'est très
bruyant en terme de musique alors c'est
pas que de la musique cubaine et là il
ya beaucoup de de reggae t-on enfin de
reggaeton pas si c'est ça le reggaeton
ouais vraiment musique d'amérique latine
également payant il ya un terme
particulier donc c'est beaucoup de bas
c'est tout en entendant les voitures
dans les maisons dans les tous les
étages les mecs à vélo les taxis à vélo
ils me disent on met sous leur siège
avec des lumières nous tous donc c'est
vrai on faisait fait les fêtes de fin
d'année sur la vague ça on a tenu à
faire ça nous donne nos épouses qui sont
venus nous rejoindre est d'accord mais
bon et ensuite le
le bonheur c'est quand on quitte les
grandes villes pour se retrouver enfin
deux sur les petites routes
là on voit là on voit les paysans va
discuter avec eux pour le peu d'espagnol
que je connaisse malgré tout on arrive à
communiquer et c'est un autre voyage qui
commence dès ce que là on est on est
dans la réalité du quotidien de ces gens
là
alors ce voyage à 70 ans ce n'était pas
votre coup d'essai puisque vous avez
voyagé à travers de nombreux pays vous
êtes aussi un ancien grand sportif vous
avez pratiqué le rugby alors les pays
traversé à vélo la france l'espagne le
portugal et le canada qu'est ce qui vous
motive dans ses voyages qui est un
objectif derrière l'objectif d'abord
c'est de réaliser un génie généralement
des rêves comme ça qu'ils viennent
l'hiver oui je me dis tiens ce sera de
mon prochain mon prochain défi
j'aime bien faire ça me fixer des
petites marches comme ça dans ce plan
musical que sur le plan sportif j'aime
bien avoir des repères et puis ce qui me
motive c'est c'est le fait de partir à
l'aventuré entre guillemets parce que
c'est quand même pas c'est pas paris
pékin
mais ce sont des aventures quotidiennes
je sais que je vais partir pour 70 ou 80
km le matin quand je me lève je sors de
ma tante
je sais que je vais être quelque part
pas très loin mais dans un autre univers
avec d'autres personnes dans un autre
décor et avec d'autres anecdotes
racontées de nouvelles aventures en
scène chaque jour dernière question
alain crampons là les prochaines
aventures est ce que vous vous il y
avait déjà pensé bruit oui alors le
carnet de vacances et
et pleins gels envie de faire le tour de
cubes de ce cube le tour sa légèreté
d'accord peillac puisque je vais fait en
partie j'ai fait le sud à vélo je vais
initiés ma chère et tendre au
cyclotourisme puisqu'elle va bientôt
être disponible pour ça sur des petites
distances histoire de l'amener doucement
là dessus et puis sinon j'avais pensé
aussi à la vallée d'aoste
tous les jours tous les jours il me
vient une idée un peu plus saugrenues et
c'est bien comme ça soit en tout cas du
plein d'aventurés encore merci à
marseille d'avoir été avec le raté de
faire le tour de cuba et à vélo une
partie en tout cas merci d'être là
d'avoir est avec pour refermer ce
journal on le referme sur la suite de
notre dossier de la semaine dédiée à la
culture urbaine dans les yvelines et on
ne peut pas parler du sujet sans évoquer
le hip hop les prémices remontent aux
années 1970 dans le quartier du bronx à
new york et longtemps mal considéré
c'est aujourd'hui un genre musical est
une danse à part entière ainsi
l'enseigné aux plus jeunes à maurepas
camille lambert et nicolas landry ont
suivi un cours
[Musique]
le rythme dans la peau ces élèves
perfectionnent leurs chorégraphies
à peine âgée de 8 ans est déjà en plein
apprentissage du hip hop tu peux
m'expliquer ce que tu as fait
aujourd'hui par la danse les
échauffements et les abdominaux
j'aimais bien danser
c'est ma copine sina m'avait donné envie
d'essayer une envie venus par le bouche
à oreille mais si le hip hop est
aujourd'hui considérée comme une danse
comme les autres elle n'a pas toujours
profité d'une bonne réputation
et
[Musique]
né dans les années 70 dans le bronx
quartier connu de new york pour ces
gangs et ses trafics de drogue
la culture hip hop se développe dans les
années 80 90 des artistes comme haïti ou
en de bellouet favorise son ouverture
n'est véhicule une image violente
[Musique]
professeur depuis 15 ans au sein de
l'association illicites dance
adeline a noté une véritable évolution
dans les mentalités
je pense qu'il ya eu un phénomène de
mode aussi je pense que les émissions
aussi comme les star académie ce genre
de choses qui ont ouvert la danse tout
simplement la danse au terme large
les gens ont découvert un petit peu plus
la danse et le hip hop qui était quand
même un milieu très fermé à l'époque
très sains de rue c'était vraiment une
danse de rue qui aujourd'hui est devenu
vraiment un style très moderne c'est le
sait la danse actuelle du moment cet
engouement favorise aussi la diversité
culturelle
malgré l'aspect agressif souvent mise en
avant le mouvement hip hop se veut une
culture de respect et de mixité sociale
vous avez vu les les les petites têtes
de denges que j'ai dans mon cours qui
viennent faire du hip hop
donc ça c'est juste génial en fait c'est
plus c'est pu réserver 1
[Musique]
à une tranche sociale en fait c'est plus
à l'époque comme on disait c'est ce
qu'avait pas trop les moyens qui faisait
ça un peu tout seul de leur côté
aujourd'hui non c'est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde
un style que chacun peut pratiquer à une
seule condition est un conseil pour être
bon au wip compter pour connaître les
pas pour est très sûr la musique pour
tous voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal c'est à revoir notamment sur
notre application mobile atv 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]